Good evening.
It was cloudy with occasional rain today.
A warm and humid maritime airstream is affecting the coastal areas of Guangdong.
Meanwhile, pressure is rising over central China.
Today's temperatures ranged from 20 to 21.9 degrees Celsius...
...with a relative humidity between 95 and 98 percent,...
...moderate to fresh easterly winds.
The current temperature is now standing at 21.9 degrees Celsius...
...with a relative humidity at 97 percent.
10.7 millimeters of rain has been recorded since midnight.
Cloudy with a few rain patches tonight.
Tomorrow, it'll cool significantly and temperatures will range from 18 to 23 degrees,...
...and it will be mainly cloudy in the following few days.
Tomorrow's API is forecast at 20 to 70,...
...and the pollution level will range from low to high.
The maximum UV index forecast for tomorrow will be about 3.
Now, to the latest global weather update.
Cloudy in Shanghai and Xiamen.
Showers in Guangzhou, rainy in Macau.
Rainy in Seoul and Tokyo.
Thunderstorms in Bangkok, sunny in Manila.
Thunderstorms in Kuala Lumpur and Singapore.
Sunny in New Delhi, Karachi and Mumbai.
Sunny in Cairo, showers in Nairobi...
...and it's bright in Sydney and Auckland.